how much power does the author have are
they an architect or a gardener this is
an episode that's going to tie into a
few other subjects namely Dietetics and
the therapy and argument what I want to
discuss real quick is the power and
limitation of the author first we need
to take some time to settle what exactly
we're talking about when we say the
author it's a term that I end up using a
lot but it has two different contextual
meanings the first and the more common
use is the hypothetical author this is
essentially what Barth is called the
author God the authority behind the
message of the text or the singular
concept of the texts creator the reason
I say hypothetical is because in most
cases like film television and video
games the text is the product of several
if not dozens if not hundreds of direct
contributors and decision makers and
stakeholders in cases like that the
author is really just a mental shorthand
conglomerate of all those people
tangentially Bart's argument for the
death of the author is rooted in this
fact that the author is often a nebulous
mix of influences and Nautica poriyal
singular person in his case he cited a
15th century compilation of Arthurian
legends written by multiple authors
across several centuries then compiled
and heavily edited by Sir Thomas Malory
the author is thusly no one person
making biographical analysis
functionally pointless the second is the
literal flesh-and-blood person who has
to sit in front of a blank page and
write crap down that is the author that
we're talking about today the
decision-maker during the creative
process for clarity for the rest of the
episode we're going to refer to the
writer when we're talking about this
role I guess we could use Barth's word
script or yeah these days that sounds
more like a Shakespeare theme he-man
villain even though they might actually
be a painter or character modeler or
costume designer we're also going to be
skewing the discussion towards the
construction of plot and story and
character so even though a lot of the
principles do apply to other disciplines
the examples will mostly involve writing
so that person the writer how much power
do they have over the text well all of
it in fact they have so much power that
writers intentionally give themselves
restrictions in order to both challenge
themselves and to escape the pressure of
possibility overload restrictions like
genre or poetic form or a specific
setting now many writers will softly
disagree with this they will insist that
their process is more akin to gardening
that when they write they get into a
zone where the words just flow out and
feels like they're not composing so much
as they are transcribing something out
of the ether something novel but
familiar they can cultivate the story or
guide it in a specific direction but
they can't truly control it they ask
what if and then write down the logical
answers this is an illusion as a writer
this is your brain playing tricks on you
as it constructs something novel out of
the things you already know the writer
as Gardner is ultimately an expression
of style and preference and not fact now
to back up a bit this is not a slam by
any means the cultivation approaches no
more or less valid than haiku or sonnet
or any other constraint and method the
results are no more or less authentic
but there are also no less subject to
the whims and preferences of the writer
the risk is mistaking the self-imposed
limitations of process for the
limitations of reality this is important
to keep in mind because the writer has
the power to change anything at any time
my shirt is gray now it's plaid I'm
wearing a hoodie I'm a woman I have a
hat I'm back to my original look the
video on the Thera Mian argument led to
a lot of discussion about logical
conclusions in the writing process these
are not bad discussions to have but it's
important to not confuse process and
reality not only do writers have the
power to alter anything in their story
for whatever reason they want they do it
all the time no matter what their
process is entire subplots get removed
characters get deleted or added events
get shuffled expanded removed characters
get shifted around an entire stories get
abandoned and restarted plotholes prose
characterization tone theme or overall
structure there is no such thing as a
reason too big or too small for a writer
to change whatever they need in order to
make it work the way that they want so
we can't actually ever talk about
logical conclusions to a story because
the facts that build the logic aren't
facts it's all made from the same clay
now there are many external logistical
reasons that lead to a story being the
way that it is from interference to time
constrain
to lack of skills who inattention but
it's not because it's the logical
conclusion it's because a writer built
it that way
I'm wearing a hat I'm wearing a hoodie
the hoodie is red